so resorts world opens tomorrow night it
is the first new resort on the strip in
over a decade
so resorts world is promising to really
bring the heat
as the kids say when it comes to big
time entertainment
they already have some big time
entertainment there this morning it's
bianca holman who's live inside with a
look at the stars coming to town bianca
good morning
hey good morning john good morning alex
you know what i'm coming to vegas every
chance i get that's what elvis presley
said and like they told us
they were going to have tributes to old
las vegas throughout the property and
they have
truly lived up to that now come over
here come over here i want to show you
where we are in relation to everything
so we're here at this signature entrance
of the hilton property and they've got
another entrance where the conrad is
and then we're talking about
entertainment right entertainment is all
happening here in this back portion the
5 000
seat theater the day clubs the day pools
so it's clear resorts world is trying to
make a huge
first impression with a list of world
famous
acts we're talking about an
unprecedented lineup of headlining
residencies
celine dion carrie underwood katy perry
and luke bryan
they've all inked deals to play at the
ultra high tech 5000 seat theater
just for this opening weekend party the
resort has enlisted the likes of paris
hilton we all know her
uncle cracker and darius rucker miley
cyrus she's going to perform on the 4th
of july
and day and night club they're going to
be hopping as well you know those are
going to be packed this summer
there's a singapore-based zook group and
they
have the big time dj such as tiesto zed
and dj snake
and others resorts world president scott
savella he
has called the entertainment lined up a
game changer for las vegas he says
his goal is to be the best class in
everything and so again
there's entertainment and coming up
we're going to talk business
right conventions we're known for
conventions here at las vegas
and resorts world definitely has a place
and has definitely going to
have people coming here for their
conventions because they not only have
space here
they're right across from the convention
center so we are one of the first in
here to show you a sneak peek
of what's to come reporting live from
resorts world bianca holman 8 news now